think so
No
alright
hi we're going to start in about one
minute and then it will be done at we'll
be out of here I guess talk to him down
at poly eight o'clock
hello good evening everybody good
evening thank you very much for coming
I'm Michael Reed I'm from Blue Sky
Studios in Columbia computer science and
I'm half of the organizing team for the
post parametric series the other half is
david benjamin from whom you'll be
hearing in a few moments this is the
third in a series of events that bring
together Columbia's Graduate School of
Architecture planning and preservation
and the computer science department and
the name to question broaden and reframe
the way we think about computing and
design a little retrospective imposed
parametric a few years ago David and I
were discussing the use of computational
methods in architectural design we're
thinking about how to address the
problem applicability that is how one
might critically evaluate these methods
this series is part of our response to
those discussions the idea is to bring
in speakers who are primary sources for
the more advanced technological interest
to the school without being watered down
through second or third-hand
interpretation and not to reuse the
already well-known contributors from the
architectural computation scene so to
that end tonight we have four guest
speakers with despair backgrounds with
the common experience of being able to
pursue projects over enough time they
can make the results part of the
scientific literature and I'm very much
looking forward to what they're going to
show us this evening I'd like to take a
quick moment to thank Autodesk research
and computer science department for
their gracious and generous support and
certainly the architecture school
providing such a great platform for the
series and with that I'd like to
introduce David Benjamin who's been a
series progenitor and constant source of
energy and motivation while we get these
talks organized here
thanks Michael and thanks everyone for
being here Michael it's been a pleasure
to collaborate with you on this ongoing
series and as we've said before we hope
that this can be the start of a
longer-term and deeper partnership
between the two departments architecture
and computer science so as you all know
the event tonight is called post
parametric three research but what
exactly do we mean by research to start
I want to propose that experimental
architecture is kind of in love with
innovation but innovation in many fields
is understood to come from a process of
kind of formalized R&D or research and
development which is basically
multi-year work that is focused but is
not tied too closely to any single
application but it seems that formalized
rd is kind of a challenge for the field
of architecture first rd in architecture
firms is challenging and difficult
because firms often assigned staff and
budgets based on billable hours so
research beyond a single project is
difficult to justify and i think this is
true even for large firms and even for
experimental firms but second rd is also
challenging for architecture schools
because different than engineering
departments or science departments at a
university in architecture departments
long-term funding is rare and long-term
projects beyond a single semester are
also pretty rare yet since R&D is
natural or more natural at least for the
field of computation it should not be
surprising to see that rather than being
a challenge its R&D is actually thriving
at the companies and the schools that
our presenters tonight are representing
so in this context I think that
each of our guests will present their
own flavor of research potentially R&D
but potentially other definitions of
research and I also think that each one
of our speakers will challenge those of
us in the field of architecture to
reengage innovation to move beyond our
current software buzzwords to expand our
definitions of experimental architecture
and to think differently about computing
and design with that I'd like to move
straight to our first speaker who is
Azam Khan a senior research scientist
and head of the environment and
ergonomics group at Autodesk research
his work has focused on advanced 3d
camera navigation techniques on large
displays and on pen-based interaction
recently Azam has been exploring
modeling and simulation including
physics-based generative design airflow
and occupant flow in an architectural
context and simulation visualization
based on sensor networks in 2009 awesome
founded and shared sim odd the symposium
on simulation for architecture and urban
design and part of the mission there was
to foster cross-pollination between
simulation research and architecture
research prior to that awesome has
worked at alias wavefront Adobe
microsoft and ati and he has chaired the
Alt key conference as I'm come
nice day
thanks Michael David I really appreciate
the invitation and I hope to hope to
present some of those challenges a
little about myself my five seconds of
fame is probably this little thing up in
the corner love it or hate it it's a
view cube that came out of our group is
a big team effort but I'm probably to
blame i also have done worked on a lot
of other projects as well as other teams
in obvious research of dental out of
things you can check it out i vas
research calm one of them is one of my
projects which is taking our own
building in toronto this here you can
see it is at two ten Kings drink pink to
ten king street east and we are doing a
digital version of that David mentioned
that to a highly detailed BIM model and
instrumenting the building with a
detailed sensor network to visualize how
this building really works I also have
another crazy project the parametric
human where we want to create the most
advanced biomechanically accurate model
of a human also they've mentioned samad
with with the intent of also pushing
that forward by getting sit the
simulation research community to talk to
the architecture research community and
the second years coming up first year
was a lot of fun and just recently for
any human computer interaction people in
the room just started the Chi 2011
sustainability community so talk to me
up here than that and most recently just
a founding member of the International
Society human simulation with about 30
of the researchers and that's going to
be a lot of fun too very exciting and
the thing that motivates me to do all
these crazy things is is progress I
really have to have every day something
has to get better a new idea or
something that's done and when I was
googling for progress I didn't know what
was a good image for progress I found
this one I kind of like it how it it
takes us from the city of destruction of
the celestial City and right before we
get there in the middle
see some vineyards you get through some
vineyards before you get there which is
kind of nice and also I like this shape
you know it's a familiar shape we see
both in nature and in in some of the
things we design and I think that's a
good way to learn from these other
systems which brings us to the actual
talk and it starts with I'm going to
cheat here as well and try to do to
todds and put them side-by-side this is
a story about having a 22 lives I think
it's a really helpful for everybody to
get two things going on because they
really end up in forming each other and
for me that's been certainly true with
the sustainable architecture side and
also the parametric human project they
end up having these these things that
help each other along and they all
involve this multiscale aspect of going
from the macrocosm and microcosm
parametric design physically based or
anatomically based and my goal in both
of these to have an opus open model and
then so that both the research and the
the industrial community can participate
in these things they they started in a
funny way to we had a partner faro
technologies they make these scanners
these laser scanners and they they sent
to someone who looks like a like phaser
on a robot army and they wanted us to
scan stuff my said that's cool but I
really want the environment one I want
to scan our building and so they said
okay the census one we scanned the
building there it's a combination of 53
scans actually totaling 1.3 billion
points and we scanned the outside the
street and the fifth floor you can see
there the reason you can see the fifth
floors because we didn't scan the sixth
floor or the roof and then later we
thought hey we have that stuff and we're
getting just low resolution models out
of the MRIs for working on the
parametric human project so we thought
maybe we can use the hand scanner for
scanning bones so we started working
with the department of anatomy at
University of Toronto to scan these
bones and you can see we're getting very
detailed scan
inside of that to the next step after
this starting from the physical because
we're interested in the retrofit project
in the left we wanted to go to to a
parametric model and this is an open
research project and hopefully some some
of you are interested working on this
but going from point cloud to geometry
and that's a parametric geometry is is
an open problem with I have a few ideas
about that be cool to work on if anybody
has needs a PhD topic but and then on
the other side there's more because of a
single bone is the tibia here is a
fairly consistent object it's a single
object there's no it's not like the
building where this inside and outside a
different components so there are some
standard ways to create geometry out of
that and after a bit of work we've got a
good tessellation on that one from the
point cloud but while the building is
somewhat parametric the bone really is
not so we're continuing that research to
based on curvature to try to find some
features that from which we can
determine what are the parameters to a
tibia and hence the rest of the skeleton
and then eventually organs and
everything else in terms of again
physically based we are instrumenting
the building with the addition of the
sub meters per floor that's the bottom
and then we also bought a pile of these
little sensors called fidgets and we're
hooking them up to to collect the AC
power usage temperature humidity motion
light sound co2 and then on the right we
have a physics based simulation using
maya of muscle fiber bundles this is the
level of detail we want to go to with
the parametric human and it's not
involving there's not a total match on
this double slide ideally we'd
eventually have some biosensors that
would measure these things on as you do
some actions and then we could determine
values from real usage
but fortunately we're starting from
cadaver and the other aspect is the
multiscale aspect where we actually
started if you're interested in the
research we started just by doing a some
of this 3d camera navigation work just
can I even see a multiscale data set we
talked about you hear that word here and
there but you know the standard camera
navigation tools don't even work for
these multi scale things so we did the
fair bit of work three different papers
on creating a multiscale camera that's
aware of the surroundings so that you
can it can be it can react properly
reduce speed or other things to respond
to the environment even a dynamic
environment and so on the left the level
of detail I don't even have the whole
city here but going from the floor where
we're using 53,000 watts of power based
on the sub meter how does that you know
become 602 and a hundred watts for a
single workstation this is the way we
hope to understand where all the powers
going in the building because currently
when you meet her you're building under
milk you guys me during your golden
finger but usually people have no idea
where all the powers going and that's
that's the problem you might have your
parameters your switches that you're
you're you're playing with but if the
result goes up or down you have no idea
whether some of those switches make any
difference in that and the thing that
ties these two presentations together i
think is the modeling simulation at
least for me where we want to work
towards having a collaborative open
simulation framework so that if you're
an expert in one area you're doing some
particular topic like a certain type of
glass or some kind of cogeneration
system or or in the human side if you're
if you're measuring the strength of
tendon tissue
or some other connective thing then you
could participate in this thing without
having to understand how the whole
system works this is a book by Bernie
Ziegler who came up with a lot of the
stuff in the 70s very cool guy and we're
working with him so hopefully put
together such a system which we hope to
use simha to further that work
independent of that kind of simulation
there's another kind of modeling and
simulation business which is the physics
based simulation and that applies both
to the human hand to the building in
this case on the left we have the simple
model of some air flow there from heat
coming from under under desk from the
computer and on the right we have a
paper called physical age gender design
using yo Sam's physics-based solver
we're thinking that as a unified solver
so you can put all these interacting
components together sometimes you create
a simulation where you just have a
hanging chain kind of thing or some
other thing some other physics said
effect but in this system you could
model different effects and have them
interact with each other the typical
thing we talked about as an example of
this is the soccer ball into the net so
the soccer ball can hit the net but then
the net should be able to push the
soccer ball back out and and with a
regular system they can't affect each
other like that but with this system you
can have everything running at the same
time we're doing some work also with
parallelization high performance
computing guy in the group as well now
and so he's going to help us with that
too to accelerate them but the missing
part of all of this is beyond the
physics of the the input of the Sun or
the moon or whatever is the input what
drives this thing and that's where we
get into the post parametric part beyond
the regular physics based modeling
simulation there's going to be some
modeling of of who's in control on the
left is our control system in the
basement at 210 king which is a trained
trade summit box there's two computers
basically sitting there running the
building somehow magically and on the
right we have the brain which is a an
active controller
for your body does of course many other
things but the problem is that normally
these things are just forgotten I've
even talked to like high-profile
architects and looked at some beautiful
building they they build and ask them up
by the way you know who did the control
system and they're like yeah I don't
know because it doesn't exist to them
it's it's really a detail and
unfortunately that brings me to the
challenge to the architecture community
head to the computer science community
is that we have to move to to both a
model and a controller combined system
in the human it's just difficult we
really have explicit control because we
decide what we're going to do but in
architecture we have an opportunity to
create like a natural system like a tree
there's no control system in the tree
tree just grows and gets better over
time as it grows and it'd be nice of a
building got better over time too if it
didn't get worse over time right now
most buildings they're there and then
they just get worse over time but if we
could design implicit control into the
building into the actual geometry into
the system through thermal massing and
natural ventilation techniques then you
wouldn't need a control system it would
be right there in the building itself
and that is I believe money 15 thank you
okay thanks a lot awesome our next
speaker is Jacqueline Martino who works
at the IBM TJ Watson Research Center
Jacqueline is an artist researcher
concentrating on emerging forms of
computational design and interaction
technology she combines the worlds of
art design and code in the areas of
industrial software research and
technology intersected artistic practice
she researches how people use tools and
design interactions for business
applications but also her art research
focuses on design computation as it
relates to computational drawing and
human-computer interaction in an area
that she defines as hand-drawn computing
so another I guess one of the one of the
many themes that might emerge tonight
might be this interaction between human
and computer and parametric but we'll
try to continue growing these themes as
the night goes on Jacqueline is also
active in see graph and she was this one
of the sea graft 2008 conference chairs
she's worked for several companies
including Phillips research Microsoft
Columbia University and Pratt University
and she's attended also several schools
including MIT Pratt Columbia and Mount
Holyoke Jacqueline Martino
we're going to switch audio or the law
that's need to be working for you okay
supposedly this fits in my pocket
or not
clothing design is anyone cover napisy
alright we'll see how that works sorry
you don't know yet all right okay so the
topic of my talk is flowy work in a work
flow of world and the topic title is
very picky we'll see if we can you can
deliver on that promise I'm working
basically you know David's comments
about R&D and what life is there like or
very interesting to me I'll tell you
from the get-go hear that hand-drawn
competing group is an under-the-radar
not funded collection of folks who get
together from time to time fairly
regularly and discuss some of the
difficulties and challenges that we see
happening in interaction design as it
relates to what we're talking about in
terms of Floyd work in the workflow
world before I go deep into that though
David also mentioned in my intro that my
artistic practice is around
computational drawing and I just hit a
milestone there which actually creates a
bit of a bridge to the body of my talk
so I spent a number of years analyzing
approximately 3,000 sketchbook entries
traditional sketchbook entries this is
pen on paper and creating a design
language to be able to generate future
forms that are similar in style and
spirit to the hand-drawn examples from
the traditional sketchbook and from that
design language here a shape grammar if
people are familiar with that body of
literature I use what I learned through
an algorithmic understanding of my of my
forms to then ground future paintings in
this case the painting on the right is
inspired by the understanding of the
forms in the the computational way and
is also interesting to note that the
painting is entirely digital not
computed but supported by computational
tools that you're probably familiar with
the Wacom tablet and in this case corel
painter so with that understanding of
life I basically see the world through
the artist lens yet I earn a paycheck
through the the role of interaction
designer how do we bridge this and how
do I get about seven other people who
aren't billing hours to to collaborate
on conversations and basically frame the
problem that I'm going to present to you
today so hand-drawn computing what is it
well first before I get into what it is
who needs it so this is a drawing if
you're familiar of kokkola he's predates
da Vinci by about a hundred years this
is 15th century and he was an artist
engineer so this is the example that
I'll use to illustrate who needs this
kind of support basically anyone who
uses the mark to work out some problem
and I was very encouraged to see as I
was waiting and while you're all waiting
for this to start a number you actually
have traditional sketchbooks or pads and
real pens in your hand and I think
that's pretty exciting so when we think
about what a mark is it's any additive
or subtractive act with any instrument
on a surface so we can be metal point it
can be pen it can be pencil it could be
stone and chisel but the thing that's
going on here is that as you're marking
your service in some way you're having a
conversation with yourself or you're
using it to converse with others to
explain what you're on about and so
basically anyone who needs this is an
artist designer scientist or engineer
and if I left anybody else please let me
know so what do we know already about
mark making these things are not going
to be illuminating to you but let's
review them in any case the mark is very
fluid or flowy its dynamic expressive
and ambiguous and it always speaks to
something is happening in in the
illustration here to the right cave
paintings of the Stone Age what's in
process here is the story the story is
being told but also as you're working in
your sketchbook you're discussing with
others your own
way somewhere with some thoughts trying
to solve a problem so what might you not
know about the importance of the mark
well what you might not know is that
this combination of the mark and the
substrate is a very very empowering
combination and what you're essentially
doing there is creating a problem space
it's a dynamic problem space because as
you Adam are or if you just simply ricci
the marks you've previously made your
reframing your problem you're posing
potentially new solution and this oven
of itself in and of itself is worthy of
some kind of a computational support
that doesn't stop the flow what we're
calling the flowy part of the work the
vision end of the spectrum if you want
to think of it that way but the reality
is that rarely is there computational
support for this part of the spectrum
for the flowy work part so hand drawn
computing back to our initial question
what is it we're working on that and
we're working on in a very flowy dynamic
kind of way and even as recently as this
this morning when the team got together
for their brief touch base we're still
working on what is it but I will extract
from you for you a bit of the static
picture of this morning and we're at the
point where we're saying that you did
support for the principal importances of
hand on problem solving in the
transformation from marks to model
algorithmic representations so if you
roll back your mind to the piece of
finish work I showed you from my own
artistic practice in that case we are
using the hand-drawn the sketch book
entries we're supporting it with some
kind of a graphical visual
representation a language that helps us
understand how the rhythmic Lee what's
going on and then it that provides
support or a bridge to another product
in the case that I showed you there I'd
usually so what if we don't pursue this
what is life like without the potential
of hand on computing well we're
essentially on this one way row from
perception a flowy end of the
to function on the workflow end of the
spectrum and really what do I mean by
that if your tools are limiting you to
picking from the previously defined
entities a well-qualified shape from a
shape palette a template from something
like PowerPoint the only thing really
that can happen is that the predefined
things determine the things that come
next right so all your compositions then
are informed directly but what you by
what you've already decided now this
isn't a bad thing it's very appropriate
in certain contexts however what we're
talking about is keeping that support
from the flowy end to the workload in
and another way that I think of this and
as we describe it is to keep the
bindings from happening too early or too
often and for every person in the room
you probably have some association to
what you think of finding is and I would
argue that whatever that association is
is the correct one if you're thinking of
it as variable bindings if you're
thinking of it you know as lashing
things down as a sailor might whatever
that conjures for you is what we mean
here if you confine yourself to early
the flowy end of the spectrum gets
filtered too early or truncated a bit
too early so from employee work here's
an example as an interaction designer on
the perceptual space where we might
start and this is an actual
representation of working out a design
for a feature that was being added to an
existing prototype and here it's the
whole environment is is on the vision
side it's supple if there's an ambiguity
are these rectangles buttons are they
displays what are they we can come at
this from multi directions we're
unconstrained and unbounded and as we
move through to the workflow to enter
the functional space we are quite
literally you've all heard the term
reducing things to practice I don't
think anyone's ever heard the term let's
amplify the practice right it's about
anything concrete because we're actually
making things
at this point right and it's not
adaptive your unidirectional constraint
and by necessity bounded so if we look
and we think about the spectrum for
marks two models or borrowing from gold
artists scientists tends to be towards
the vision end of the spectrum and the
designer engineer towards the practice
with all these other characteristics
that I've already described there's a
whole lot of gray space there in the
middle right so on the right end of the
spectrum they're currently available any
number of tools to help support this
part of the process less so on left and
very nearly nothing bridging the space
so what's our approach we call this mix
fidelity it's a mixing of marks and
models so we want to be able to support
the artistic gesture but we don't want
to always recognize everything so if you
think of it in the way of like sketch
recognition sometimes not everything
needs or wants to be recognized
sometimes it just needs to be there
right we also want the ability to unbind
what's been recognized so here's the
fully formed shot of a working
implementation that came from in some
part a very open-ended visualization but
what's very interesting here is only a
small part of this actually becomes
fully qualified right so if you go in a
very kind of literal sense you say
everything on my flowy side needs to
eventually be in the model and be fully
qualified well probably not in the way
people are actually and truly working
there's only some really small
percentage that actually makes it into
the final design now this doesn't mean
that all the other bits are worthless
they might come into play at some other
future time so we don't need them to be
lost so just to conclude I'll place up
here our definition again and I'll also
try to summarize for you what why I
think well where we are in terms of you
know one of the briefs for this talk was
you know what's our future thought here
and when you work in enterprise research
typically what you find
is what you're working on now is
something that will enter into product
and say 15 to 20 years depending who you
listen to and who you read so part of
trying to figure that out is looking
backwards and say well where were we 15
or 20 years ago and I can draw a small
analogy here with the book 15 or 20
years ago there was great computational
support already growing for writing but
the digital book for reading didn't
really exist it's coming into its own
now right and I think we're in a similar
place with drawing and the impact that
drawing can have if you look back about
10 or so years you have products like
the Wacom tablet but now you're getting
these other very interesting products
like the Livescribe pens if you're aware
of these and if we start to think in
terms of the software that we can
develop that we can use to support this
notion of Thrawn going forward drawings
on going away your pen and your paper
may go away to the degree that your book
has gone away but now we're getting into
the reading writing phase of drawing so
I would say if you're going to take
anything away from you now from this
talk it would be to think about how
you're using drawing and how you might
be using drawing in some futuristic
world and those are going to be really
hard problems and we're just starting to
work on the mouth in our under-the-radar
group that hopefully will have the kind
of funding that David envisions for
enterprises thank
yeah okay thank you Michael I thought
I'd just motivate my talk by showing you
this this is a canon g7x camera costs a
few hundred dollars and captures 10
megapixel images field and we probably
have one question is if you wanted to
capture a 10 megapixel image a hundred
years ago what would you use any idea
well here's a camera that did it for you
it weighed 1400 pounds so about 12 feet
long and it took about 15 people to
operate so the point that I'm trying to
make is that the evolution of the camera
in the last hundred years has been truly
remarkable on the other hand was also
fascinating is that the fundamental
model underlying the camera has remained
essentially the same which is the camera
obscura or what we refer to as the
pinhole camera model so that's what we
call the traditional camera the
traditional camera uses a detector or
some sort and a lens and this lens is
what we refer to in computer vision as a
perspective lens and it essentially
captures or accepts those rays of light
that pass through the effective pin hole
or the center of projection of the lens
to produce your familiar linear
perspective image so let's just think
about this for a second if you consider
this room right here you have an
infinite number of light rays bouncing
around this is what we refer to as the
light field associated with this space
it's actually a high-order entity a
high-dimensional entity and what the
traditional camera does is that it
performs a very simple and restrictive
sampling of this very complex light
field that is from this infinite set of
light rays it accepts the only those
rays of light that
from the effective control of the camera
so the point I'm trying to make is that
if you somehow manage to map seen raised
two pixels in some unconventional
fashion maybe we can capture new types
of pictures and that's really the
motivation behind the computational
camera which uses new optics to map seen
raised two pixels in some unconventional
fashion so here I'm showing this yellow
ray which should have gone all the way
down to the bottom of the detector but
it's been redirected to this pixel and
it came in as being a yellow ray but
it's been altered to a red red before it
arrives in the pixel so in all cases the
computational camera uses optics that
captures or producers and optically
coded image and the coding is done in
some meaningful fashion and that's where
the computational module comes in it
knows everything it needs to about the
optics and this pepper is able to
computationally decode the image after
the fact after capture to produce
hopefully a new type of image so it's
this line of work that we've been
pursuing along with others and the
computer vision lab at columbia and what
i want to show you are just a couple of
examples of computational families so
here's one that allows you to capture a
very large field of view we can all
agree that it's somehow if you can
capture the entire sphere around the
point that would have profound
implications not only for computer
vision but for a wide variety of
applications so here is a very early
implementation is there a point of any
time a very early implementation so here
you see your favorite digital still
camera attached to it is this funky
contraption which has a bunch of lenses
in here and a curved mirror and you can
see how if you capture an image with
that system you get something that looks
it's a couple of things not about this
first is the black spot in the center
and this is where the mirror seeds the
lens is the inherent blind spot to this
type of the system the second thing to
notice that the field of view is very
large since significantly larger than a
hemisphere that is unlike a fisheye lens
which I'm sure you're familiar with in
this case although the picture was taken
close to the ground level you're able to
capture the sky which is well above the
bleachers right there and the third
thing to note is that the image is
distorted or from our perspective it's
optically coded and since we have
satisfied some conditions in designing
the system and we understand the optics
of the system we can take any part of
this image and map it to a linear
perspective image after the fact for
that matter we can freely roam around
the space exactly the same thing can be
done by using an array of cameras and
stitching the pictures together which is
a very common practice but here we are
talking about a single camera without
any moving parts being able to capture a
moment but with an unusually large field
with you so back in 96 this is with my
student Venkat theory we demonstrated a
video conferencing system and here you
see
group of people sitting around in a
similar contraption but this time at
actual video camera and this was 96
we're talking with very low resolution
video that looks like that bunch of
people around it and then from justice
and using no more than a PC or a laptop
computer any number of these perspective
video screen they give you the illusion
of multiple cameras and this technology
has really come a long way there's a
company called remote reality then
builds these cameras for both defends as
well as commercial applications and we
are able to produce now a 4 megapixel
image at 15 frames per second you can't
really show that kind of video using
PowerPoint but you can sort of imagine
what it looks like so that's field of
view that's a computational camera I
want to show you a different example a
different dimension if you were and so
that's this one right here joint work
with sujit put pyramid so what we did in
the previous case was to capture a very
wide field of view by using a convex
mirror let's take a look at what you can
do with a concave mirror so in this case
you have an SLR camera placed in front
of it this time is a hollow cone that's
mirrored on the inside circles and now
an interesting thing happens if you're
looking at one point in the scene then
that point of course gets captured
directly by the the lens of the camera
because it's a whole of corn but it
turns out that it gets captured exactly
two more times via reflections by the
cone exactly two more in other words
each point in the scene is captured
three times but in the same image but
seen from three different viewpoints you
see what I'm saying so you take this
contraption and if you point it at an
object for example a face in this case
you get an image that looks like this in
the center you have this unobstructed
linear perspective view that's the whole
of corn but in this distorted annulus
you have an end
heading of two additional views say and
this image has an interesting structure
to it which is that if you take any
particular feature in the central image
its corresponding projections in this
distorted annulus must lie on a line
that passes through the center of the
end that's a very interesting feature or
property of this type of them now
essentially what you have is three
images embedded in and it turns out that
you can then tear apart these three
images after the fact and once you have
these three different views you can
reconstruct the three-dimensional
structure of the face from the single
quarter so that's that's exploring the
dimension of death
okay let's talk about another type of
computational time this is a very
important dimension that all camera
manufacturers are actually scrambling to
address as we speak it's called dynamic
range you open your eyes you see a scene
it will invariably have an enormous
range of right mrs. in college very rich
in detail you take a camera and you take
a picture each one of those brightnesses
get mapped to one of 255 values in each
pixel that's eight bits of information
in other words digital cameras really
fall short with respect to film for
example in the sense that they simply
cannot measure the richness of the real
work the visual world all the details so
this is something that manufacturers are
looking at have been for the last five
years and the traditional approach is to
take multiple pictures using different
exposures so you can see here that this
is a very short exposure on the left and
the brightest regions are captured well
but the dark regions are just completely
done the other extreme you have a very
long exposure and the dark regions are
captured well but the bright regions are
just watched out but you can imagine
computationally after the fact taking
these multiple images and somehow taking
the best information from each one and
and combining it to create what we call
a high dynamic range image that is
although these individual images at
eight bits of information at each pixel
this one down here has 12 bits of
information
okay this is something you can try on
Photoshop right it's available for
everyone to use the problem of course is
that while these pictures are taking are
being taken either the scene the world
could change or the camera could move
you would love to do exactly the same
thing but with the click of a single
picture so here's the idea this is joint
work with thermo matsunaga right here at
the bottom there you have some seen in
this sort of caricature in the scene and
here you have a chip this is your CCC CD
or CMOS chip that's sitting inside your
digital still camera and in any said
chip all pixels on the chip are made
equal in terms of sensitivity and so you
could have a huge part of the sky washed
out or you could have a huge part of the
person too dark and once this
information is lie lost you simply
cannot recover you can maybe you can
have this innate it but you can't
recover the real information so the idea
is to create a chip with unequal pixels
and one way to do it there are many
different ways to do this but one way to
do it is to place on top of the chip and
optical mask think about sun shades of
different transmittances or different
levels of darkness so here you see that
you have the sort of checkerboard
pattern of sun shades and so now if you
have a pixel that's washed out too
bright you likely have a neighbor that's
not and if you have a pixel that's too
dark you likely have a neighbor that's
not in other words the good data
irrespective of how complex and bright
and dark asinus the good data is
interspersed with the bass of all bad
data and you can take the good data and
the bad data and reconstruct with it
computationally after the fact a very
high dynamic range image without
sacrificing resolution
by any sort of noticeable amount so this
idea was prototyped by sony this is
Sony's cybershot camera inside it is
this assorted pixel chip that we're
talking about and you can see here that
all chips all image sensors have red
green and blue pixels in them but this
one has different shades of red green
and blue pixels and you take a single
shot with it and you can reconstruct a
hopefully high and dynamic image image
so for comparison here are two scenes
captured with your your old sony
cybershot camera that's just a regular
camera and you can see on the top and
the bottom regions that are washed out
and regions that are way too dark in the
shadow and the exactly the same scene
shot using the assorted pixel camera and
you'll see that there's an enormous
amount of detail that jumps out there is
every extra bit that you're able to
capture gives you much more it's not
linear in the best it's 2 to the power
of whatever the number of bits my 3 wow
ok last piece so now I want to talk to
you about something that has less of its
less of a research result but more
hopefully has more of a social impact
that that was essentially our goal if
you look at cameras in the marketplace
today they look something like this you
probably own one of these and the point
that I'm trying to make is that these
cameras lack of silver fact that
features have really been developed for
and marketed to us grown-ups and in
doing so I believe that camera
manufacturers have
the huge demographic and kids and a
really compelling application in
education now of course you can buy
cameras for kids but those are toys
there's a very inexpensive very cheap
pieces of plastic that if your kid
breaks you're okay with it that's the
idea that but here we are talking about
how one could actually leverage this
really special place that cameras have
in society to make it a medium for
instruction for education so I've been
thinking about this for a long time
since 2006 or so and this is what I came
up with in it ultimately unfortunately
offends me everything that's on the
screen many of the parts are missing but
the camera comes to you as a kid and the
idea is for kids and you know kids love
putting things together it's for kids to
put these pieces together and as you put
these pieces together for example it has
a hand crank and a power generator so
you even without a battery you can crank
it a few times and take a picture why
would you do that it's not because
batteries are expensive but it's because
it allows you to teach about magnetism
electro-mechanics and about power
storage and capacitors so each one of
these pieces is used as an opportunity
to teach so here are some of the steps
involved in putting this together very
much like a legal kit if you will and
then a teacher or parent or or a grower
or self motivated student would pause
opting each one of these pieces and then
go off and read from an interactive
textbook that we have online about all
of these different concepts so its stem
education and once you're done putting
it together you get this it's a camera
called Big Shot big shot of course is a
play on words it's the idea of teaching
little kids all of this stuff and
turning them into big shots hopefully
even underrepresented and
underprivileged kids and here is a big
shot and it has it has instead of a
single lens it actually has three
settings to it you see these three
settings right here one is just an
move you like a cell phone type of field
of view the second one is a panoramic
view about 80 degrees and the third one
is stereo you actually capture two
pictures in one image and then after the
fact you can create a 3d picture and
anaglyph where you can wear red green
glasses and see what your shot in 3d and
then if you turn it around it's
completely bare the idea is to sort of
provoke conversation you can talk about
the mechanics of it you can see all the
different parts that are laden up there
it has a 1 watt LED for a flash so that
you can talk about semiconductors and PN
junctions and all that good stuff so
that's the camera and we build exactly
12 of these and we took them all over
the world for different countries and
did tests with them a few hundred kids
just to see how this works out and i
have to tell you we've never had to drag
a kid through it the morning session was
building and learning the afternoon
session was shooting your pictures
coming back and then downloading and
uploading your pictures of favorite ones
and they all just sort of really where
we actually got offers for the camera
which is one kid offered us three
hundred dollars for the camera and the
Aster where is it your money is
my bad so here's a bunch of the kids
just putting the camera together other
camera
this may actually surprise you but some
of these kids especially the ones in
India had never used a camera before it
just seems desire in today's context
it's true but it's amazing to me how
quickly they caught on to it I just show
you a couple of pictures and then you
could go to the website and see the rats
running out of time but very quickly
just say that if you have kids in your
lives or if there's still a kid inside
of you please visit bigshot camera at
all thank
um our next speakers work is in
interaction methods generator design
fabrication and the intersection of
architecture interaction design and
pervasive computing lyra nikolushka as a
principal designer autodesk for the past
three and a half years she's worked on
new conceptual design tools for their
Revit product which I'm sure if you're
familiar with or will be soon we're
holding PhD and design a computation for
MIT architecture and worked in the
computer computing culture group at the
Media Lab prior to joining Autodesk she
worked the strategic design department
Phillips design and prl of folks
research labs in briarcliff and she's
taught at RISD and Technical University
I to open she used the chair for the
curated art at siggraph 2008 and she's
going to talk about interaction design
for future dim systems thank you you
near the top left side is a table and
make furniture and I still continue to
make furniture I think it's very
important to engage with the material
aspect of what we are talking about and
that is a project that was done in the
computing culture group while I was
student there which is actually a quick
conversation table with pretty much
morning towards the patterns of speech
so depending like who speaks i mean it's
actually visualizes by lighting up the
leds went back and forth who actually
dominate conversation like that's
bringing forward some of the invisible
aspects of conversations the project
from the left hand side here in the
bottom coincides with the start of my
job at autodesk it's via siggraph 2008
gallery and while the goal actually is
to bring forward the fact that the
emergence of digital tools and methods
used by contemporary designers and
architects have been connected as
Michael pointed out with developments in
computer graphics and if the goal was
also to point out that things have not
really started there they actually
started with is a car it started with
actual
a very concrete design need and his
invention not only revolutionized the
textile industry it also embodies the
ability to control a sequence of
operations and fabricate the end result
all in one goes so in that context in
addition to having contemporary
architecture also had designers and
architects actually look at for example
Islamic patterns they look at Chinese
iswe grammars from the 17th century we
catch textile rivers and so for people
that look at for example applicant pool
bar textiles and they're doing
contemporary rotating your
interpretations using contemporary
technologies so while we talk about
computation I think we frequently forget
where we actually come and focus on
what's in front of us today the projects
on the right-hand side are the ones that
I'm going to talk very briefly like here
it's basically what I will focus on is
love usually research methods that we
employ at Autodesk both shorter term for
every one of the releases and also like
a longer term so I'll just jump through
this stuff like stripes paper here could
be obvious slide I was able to find as
why the textual describes bin okay and I
don't think I will go into description
of a bin because I know for a fact that
you have somebody called David planner
on your faculty who teaches side of it
who teaches that just illustration of
the actual design process and how the
textual is being impact Arabic is a
parametric associative modeling so for
however given the different phases of
the design process and the kinds of
folks that has been given to what the
tool actually is the majority of the
workflow is focused in design
development and actually construction
documents and that's how the truth would
be actually perceived through through
the time so what we actually did for
this particular project we focused on
this two phases up here so the goals of
the project was to try to make creation
of complicated geometry and Briggs a bit
simpler to make to persist the
relationship with the BIM model not only
to look at geometry and for
but also the paramedic relationship that
the drive the form and I promise this
will be on with one of the few text
slides but I have done so how do you go
about doing that it's actually quite a
lengthy process and we call this slide
the subway cards boston subway card
slides so what you will see is that
there is a process of approximately six
seven months what the red parts of text
signify I don't know if you're able to
read any one of them is every time we
have actually went to an end user
whether it is a university or in
architecture office and talk to them so
this is like the frequency with which we
have actually talked to people before we
even started designing the tools or also
like while we were designing the tools
the blue bits are actually departs we're
actually doing activity so it starts
with New York user research November
2007 and like think that we start here
but then you release the soul for
approximately a year and a half after
that so it takes like so much time as
designers I mean also and also it's like
me as a furniture maker frequently think
about how designers actually connected
with their tools I mean whether their
interaction designers whether they're
architects whether their furniture
makers in and and so forth and you are
like frequently faced with the dilemma
is that do you build like a very
specialized tool like a chisel or like a
very generalized tool like something
like this right and oh no so like what
happens if you build the generals too I
mean what are the kinds of other tools
like rings right like this one here that
can like further push the tool from what
it was designed to do and if you start
thinking about that I mean like what
we're looking for today world this is
not that different I mean there by
modeling environments and people either
construct rigs like such as in this case
or they custom script to be able to
augment what they need to do so we did
like all of that research we also like
went and I mean this is interesting
because we're talking about post
parametric write and post parametric
assumes that there is a mature
technology and that has already become
the common but we ran this survey at
University of december two thousand
seven this is couple of years ago and we
asked people what tools you're currently
using the early conceptual designs of
projects sketchup this is like 300
people that replied approximately i
would say like how much this is like 75
to 80 percent of them use Sketchup I
mean what we know companies that make
for something like seven to eight
hundred Sketchup models and the question
the varies like why they're doing it and
the answer is local one of the many
answers it because I mean these tools
are really very accessible and the
question is whether parametric modeling
tools are really accessible we
identified two user groups the ones that
we actually interviewed when we started
researching is a group that we called a
teacher group and this was a group that
totally doesn't lead us they make their
own tools the existing medium and large
architecture companies they also exist
in academia there are small units they
have a head suffered a major impact of
2009 and the economy declined because
this U is actually shrink they're
considered research units they either
are embedded in project for the work as
consultants and they frequently share
findings within the larger group and
then there is a second group which is
actually an aspiring group these are
people that you don't have research
groups they don't have the budget to
make these explorations and but they
still are interested in the kinds of
things as the others group is actually
doing so what we did is that while we
were learning from the top group what
table we would build will test with the
group that was aspiring so that would
actually ensure that the kinds of tools
were doing are actually going to be more
accessible to like a larger audience we
frequently I mean this is something
which is very unusual in the
human-computer interaction community but
doesn't happen even in the world of
tool-making for for architects by
architects I'm trained as an architect
myself we built that phone and these are
stereotypical users so here is like a
profile of a user so when do we go about
to the next step you know the queen bee
design scenarios workshops and so forth
we frequently ask ourselves for who are
we actually
I mean what is this 244 who is it
subsequent activities that that follow
are also design workshops this is with a
group of approximately 20 architects
from north america and the aia and the
other the bubbles they are because we
protect the privacy of people that we
work with this is like a type of
artifact that comes out from these
workshops it's a scenario and this I
picked this one because it's a really
goofy one but I mean on the same side
you need to get like people are
comfortable about you know interacting
write this stuff but although it's about
the wing farm and the geese the kinds of
issues that are actually being addressed
in the scenario is factual data dynamic
analysis through time presentation of
results multiple groups actually
collaborating the next step while you
build the scenarios is actually creating
a storyboard so here like together with
people that are actually end users we're
looking at their thought process how
they would like to go about making a
curtain system design in six easy steps
I can never make a correct and system
design in its six easy steps but still
you learned that we first need to
understand the problem they need to
understand the material understand
technology design methodology
manipulation with light iterations of
form and like so so forth so when we go
back to the office we look at all of
that material and we generate very
detailed story board this is like a dis
thick book litter that is being
developed that actually identifies like
in a narrative form and visual form
exactly what has happened so here you
see that first you start to understand
the program in the site then you start
constructing parametric Greeks you start
to slowly maybe rationalize the form you
like run early conception energy
analysis like all the way to creating
like facade studies and so forth this is
like only one of the possible scenarios
that you can do it and then at this
point you're ready to start designing
you still are not designing so what you
do is you generate concept sketches this
is more probably like familiar to like
what you're already doing your Creator
expects you iterate with other designers
development queue and so forth and
there's this loop
happens here like numerous provisions
except this is not all of it this is
actually the full process there is
another part that comes here in which on
this left side what I mentioned about
user research is just like you know this
part here you also are looking at what
is the current state of the stock for
how far can you push it with the idea
that you have had any other colleagues
done any work and also what are the
other presidents you can learn from okay
what we do next is may we make a lot of
paper prototypes the thing is that you
can push paper prototypes only so far
I'm either really not interactive enough
but then when you are dealing with
interactive prototypes here's the
dilemma this is like I've ever 2009 um
which is two releases back and at this
time we were going through a major
redesign of the user interface which
actually means that you can start
understanding how many icons are there
so if you're going to be like working
with people that only you want to focus
their attention on the conceptual design
tools and people that maybe don't even
know rabbit I mean how do you you know
like masters I mean the number of
commands you can think actually is the
number of workflows and interactions and
so please accept this is not all of the
commands I mean this is what we're
actually talking these are the number of
commands that actually showed up and
what we started doing is we realized
that we ought to simplify the user
interface in order to be able to put it
in front of people who are going to be
focusing only on the conceptual design
tasks and not on everything else and
this is what we found actually we need
and we arrived at this point by pretty
much like outlining workflows for
example I want to make a cube right I
want to like add parameters I maybe want
to rationalize one side I want to like
good so we had like a whole log of
workloads that actually helped us arrive
to this that translated to this
particular example the universe or
interface that we took two people that
were not familiar with rabbit and they
were able to actually test this this is
the first prototype with a variable that
we made ourselves and then I don't need
to go more into this but at this point
on which is
soon we were only six seven months in
the project and the first release which
was the next early next spring Wars was
the work that we actually did in this
part of the project so while that was an
example of how we do work like release /
release I mean the second part of the
presentation will be hard to actually
like think I mean then actually research
for what may happen after this is that
what happens like in 10 years so in the
top part what you see oh it looks much
better on my screen and their story is
that this is the short term so we work
like a by release cycle so we released
the software once a year and the opera
charge actually shows like this is like
September gent october november december
these are the months here and usually we
do like requirements analysis like
understand what's happening at this time
of the year a research you know like
scope definition conceptual design the
kinds of things that i told you about
and i refer to that processes the
harvest processed except that our
harvest is about nine months it's really
very long but then what we started doing
like exactly like this time
approximately a year ago is like this
exercise which we call beam futures and
the goal was that we engage with
colleagues both colleagues and people
that our end users whether their
customers in architecture offices and so
forth or people in academia and we start
asking them three questions and these
questions are what is the core then what
are the global trends that influence the
architecture engineering and
construction industry and the third one
is what do you think the architecture
engineering and construction in the
sphere like aacsb code is going to look
like 10 years from now just like these
three questions so we went all a bunch
of like him to design so we have the
numbers here and they're pretty crazy
rear end I think actually I have a map
uh-huh so this is not how we do like
long-term use research this is also not
cow how you do it but we almost do it
like this because we do it with cards
and have the cards here right and it's a
user
methods which is fairly well known in
the interaction design community has not
been done in architecture very much so
this was the first you know the
iteration of the cards in which were
using very autodist centric thing this
is the last iteration of the cards so we
have this blue cards which we call theme
cards and then this red cards which are
trans card and explain like how they're
being done and we have arrived at the
point with approximately twenty-two
interviews with 29 participants we have
done in-house first to actually modify
the cards to a point that we have
actually added cards like this one like
life cycle for example and we have also
removed cards and we have made them
completely productive Gnostic so we were
able to interview people that have
nothing to do with autodesk immunity
don't even like use the tools we also
developed a protocol like how do you go
about like interviewing so we can
actually give this to colleagues that go
on business trips and invited for us for
travel are like fairly limited so you
can see that here the goals are of the
product overall is to validate whether
the themes and the trends we have
identified I correct to identify
patterns and clusters and frequencies of
selections of different things and
trends how they are prioritized and also
to start comparing the gaps between what
was the internal autodesk perception and
what was the external Chris perception
and we have found some gaps so this is
like where we have done most of our
research and you can see is like at this
point North America like heavy and the
display correctly we can interviewed 35
we have had 35 introduced with customers
for 57 people at 18 sides and that's
it's like a bit architecture heavy but
we're planning to bring in engineering
and construction up and seven people in
academia with seven introducer totally
like with the other does group we have
64 hours of interviews which notes like
substantial information we interviewed
people in their offices we went to their
offices we interviewed them in a big
hotel
always like wherever we were able to
catch them the right one is in Las Vegas
at like Autodesk University we also
developed a magnetic version of the
cards when you have like multiple people
and we also developed an interactive
prototype and this is the the paper
storyboard here is another example how
you actually do that direction around
remote interviews so here is one in our
telepresence room so you actually see
the person and you just look Randy
interview as well and this generated a
ton of data so I'll just go through what
I'm going to briefly cover here and I'm
like probably like three to four minutes
away from the end I'm going to focus on
the North America end user interviews
not paternal autodesk interviews i'm not
going to be doing comparison because i
can't and i'll show you what you learn
and talk next steps so this fine
gentleman here is Andrew Marsh you
contact that's how he looks the first
question it was what is the core of them
today and you can see that every one of
the cards actually provides additional
information for the interviewer to be
helped out if they get stuck with the
person if the person doesn't like really
want to talk and here is also like a cue
that we're looking for patterns thin
clusters frequency and so forth people
really didn't have our time because of
the cars are very tangible there is a
good starting point in terms of what
passing this is a chart of what we
actually found the core of them today
according to customers like top one is
documentation followed by view
coordination and parametric so these are
with the top four cards the parametric
is fourth all the way here and this was
the biggest difference that we actually
found with the internal auditors
perception the odorous perception was
the number one was parametric I mean and
that's partially because I mean the tool
has been marketed as a documentation a
tool and you will see like one punch of
like gaps here when you start like
breaking down for example a McQueen
structural day for example don't care
about design alternatives you can start
like breaking this data in any way you
you want I mean here is another diagram
just to like show show that lifecycle
API
vacation so far has been very low and
this is like some manifestation of how
those different arrangements of the
cards actually looked including this one
where this person actually says the
publication parameter can design
alternative is the current fashion that
everybody talks about but nobody's
really enough serious to actually deal
with that as for global trends this was
the second question we asked people to
read the six cards the one that it's
covered is economy and this was to get
them thinking toward the third question
ultimately which was the future of the
AC industry and I'll just go like very
quickly couple of quotes economy and
population are things that happen to us
these are kinds of trends that we can't
really control or sustainability will
only drive bin if it is economical
here's another one that is looking at
emerging technologies and materials most
dramatic improvements in recent
materials is glass improvements take a
long time to make a difference within 10
to 10 25 years so this is like in the
context of thinking like what is next I
mean I mean and also it came up in the
Acharya conference to use a few weeks
ago that we can model pretty much
anything you can analyze pretty much
anything but I mean we can't really
build it yet and to that point is I
would like to build a building from
carbon fiber but I don't know how the
third question ten years ahead we'll ask
the engineers to like big and discuss
top themes and trends that illustrate
where they think the industry city 10
years for now and for the other days
colleagues also ask them to roadmap that
to tell us where we need to be like in
three or six years and hear the results
fabrication is the top of this chart
followed by collaboration this is an
overlap with the other one analysis in
parametric and I mean I can go into this
diagram in lots of detail but we don't
have the time documentation is all the
way here that you start like questioning
it happen
the interviews you ask people what will
happen to documentation the telomeres
irrelevant it turns out that it's a kind
of that there is expectation that some
issues actually going to evolve that
they're going to still be present but
they're going to have a different form
here's another chart of how that looks
and here are some of the snapshots and
what we do is like with this is we like
have all the snapshots like on a whole
wall and like we're looking at the
charts and then we compare and through
through this as well you can see that
the tools are API emerging technologies
and education there is a code
collaboration with the aspect of social
networks and then these are the kinds of
topics that we'll be looking at here is
another one that is like a funnel with
collaboration coordination design
imperatives and analysis in the top
here's another one which is like so
they're very different representation or
another one here that fear is the goal
the construction is the end result and
this is what I'm going to be dealing
with in the middle so here's your quote
and as I think we heard this the
building industries ten years behind the
manufacturing and car industry if you
look how those injustice interoperate
you can map where the building industry
may go in the near future as well as a
discussion here that the model should
not be remodel that it's ridiculous
waste of time so there used to be some
better detailing if you want for
conceptual model to go straight to
fabrication okay this one I liked a lot
on collaboration that the notion of the
lone architects we're all the way in a
studio is ridiculous it is not how we
teach today and how people practice the
reality that you can engineers and so
forth they're all collaborating through
common platforms which again is very
much rooted in the design tools
innovative technologies
this one this is a just comparison slide
on the top is the core of them today on
the bottom is ace industry and you will
see that the overlaps are actually
collaboration hybrid teams ipd work but
I'm a click in the middle and
coordination which actually deals with
the real-time synchronicity to disable
so according to those people that we
asked because the kind of things that
who persist in the next 10 years so
conclusions for like this part of the
research this is not finished is that
transfer separated into things that are
out of control versus within our control
i mean how we engage with emerging
country technologies is something that
we can control that beam today is
actually different from what AC will be
in 10 years I don't even know if they're
we live in 10 years maybe there will be
and overlap is Claude racially the
coordination in parametric model we
assume post documentation paradigm the
question is how is that going to be
voting and that beam is as much by
processes about the virtual model what
is next we are planning the visioning
workshop we have been in conversations
with a university in Boston to actually
have a workshop much like the one that I
showed you earlier for the early phases
of the conceptual design environment in
which we look at sub-theme some of the
like high scores if you want and also
like the lower lows course and engage
academia industry like us from the
software industry and see like if you
can come up with some more concrete
future scenarios and then also
introducing different regions
okay and we'll try to keep that to you
know 15 minutes or so and maybe just two
so I'd like to invite all of the
speakers up to the table here maybe just
to start it off I want to make a quick
observation that of course it seems like
we could probably have an entire
conference about the the subject matter
of each one of the four different
presentations you know awesome is
already doing the conference about
simulation but it seems like the idea of
hand drawing as it relates to computer
tools as a whole other conference
certainly visualization and cameras and
optics and the way that we see the world
but also see design and represent our
designs because there are cameras in
every piece of software that we use as
architects and the images that we show
to our colleagues or teachers or clients
are all camera-based images
visualizations and certainly new
software tools is already a topic and
and how we develop new features for
software tools sardia you know topic but
I just wanted to note that the point of
these post parametric events was is not
really to draw conclusions but more to
open up questions and and to allow us to
think more broadly and even though in
some respects it's a little kind of like
overwhelming or almost jarring to see
the variety of different
topics on the table I think that's
exactly fitting and that's that's you
know one of the purposes of an event
like this is to is to raise a lot of
these issues all at the same time
without a clear focus I think maybe
Michael if you want to ask the first
question and then maybe soon after we'll
open it up to questions from the
audience thank you did and thank you
speakers very much very interesting
stuff and I got you a lot of questions
for you each individually on your own
work which I mean I'm going to save okay
I've got a general question though
because you're all from different
aspects of the rng community corporate
academic even sort of side special
projects when I first started in this
field I had this idea of you know two
different types are already there was
corporate R&D which tend to be trade
secret and licensable and then there was
academic arm d which tend to be
published at conferences and basically
free I think you know certainly the
architecture communities seen the
benefit of this for example in the way
that products that were designed and
developed through billions of dollars of
R&D for the aerospace and automotive
industries are convening usable you know
for this you know for the architecture
community I was just wondering if you
felt that there was a change in the way
rd results can be
by people who aren't in the specific
field the rd's being done in I say this
because I see that more and more
academic rd is going out under license
and I see strangely enough a lot of
corporate R&D is being pushed out there
is open source projects so if you have
any ideas for films like this I would
love to hear them and a funny reversal
in them in that that we've experienced
too because my projects we want to
publish all the data and make it
accessible to the research community and
anybody really and but when sometimes
when we've gone to visit universities
they're like oh well we can't show you
that because you know that's gonna be a
spin-off or something so it is it is
kind of a real factor that's kind of
surprising I don't know why you know
whether it's this time or or it's a
pendulum that comes back the other way
it sooner or later but it's definitely
there
and I can tell you that the presentation
today I mean it was cleared by legal I
forgot to do that maybe it is because I
don't work for research lab but for in a
scenario where we work like putting
these / movies though their search of
things that need to be carefully guarded
not because as much because you're
actually worried that somebody else may
like figure out what you're doing this
because you also don't want to make
empty promises to your end-users bike
you cannot actually say that this is
what we're going to have I think you
might have something to do with sort of
the difference between engineering side
schools and more design side work just
because over time the engineering
schools are seeing that even you know
subtle ideas even simple ideas can
monetizable in a very real and immediate
way as spin-offs that can know there's
huge value there whereas say in a design
school it's i think playing more
difficult to say yeah this idea i've got
for something you know the school can
take a percentage we can translate this
into something but
talk about it because that kind of
collaboration isn't a marvelous fall to
your school or design school maybe to
build a little bit of that line of
thinking I'm curious if if any of you
have thoughts about collaboration which
has become a topic that I think Columbia
architecture school is starting to
address more and more and it strikes me
that there's there's examples of
collaboration within the development of
each of your individual research but
then also it's possible that the product
of the research enables collaborations
different kinds of collaborations
potentially but i wonder if you have
thoughts about you know if we're
thinking about the future of computing
and design are there opportunities for
collaboration say between architects and
software experts in developing the tools
and helping to kind of influence that
level of technology or do you think
there are opportunities for
collaboration in the use of the tools
that others are developing or both or or
any other thoughts about the the
potential for software and the future of
computing and design to engage
collaboration and broader ways
the designers are mainly architects
they're trained architects many of them
are actually certified architects and we
kind of understand what the problems are
but we never assumed that we know the
problems enough to engage look solely
ourselves with our software developers
and for the first project that i showed
you actually interacted with
approximately 60 to 70 people and we had
a dozen people that were our advisors
and these were practicing architect so I
mean while they were not the ones that
were necessarily driving the final
product it was after three were
certainly like working with now is for
starting an entirely new project I will
pass that question to my son well for
the city sustainability stuff I think
that's a problem high complexity and any
any kind of solution will come up with
will be highly multidisciplinary so
architects but also many other
disciplines will be involved in some
kind of solution I'd like to see every
new building be in that zero building
and some certain governments are
interested in starting that leading them
as well and that is just it's just not
that easy there are some lessons we can
learn from form architects today and we
need to to collect those and somehow
make them accessible to two as part of
academia and also sooner than later
hopefully our practice
the I really I really I would speak to
lira I really appreciated the design
watching the design process of the user
interface because i think the user
interface with impairment modeling or
scripting is something that ends up
bleeding into the specific form of
whatever you're generating a good
example being you know graphical
programming being both a user interface
and also a data flow process and i was
wondering it was there any example in
with the specific user interface changes
you're making ended up being implemented
on the level of tool for example it's
not just as a button is placed somewhere
but that some sort of specific approach
to the tool ended up changing the
dynamics of the tool itself and another
question I had was you mentioned the box
and how you sort of designed to use that
user interface around wanting to fill it
a box i wanted to do certain operations
of the box I'm I think there's really
something interesting to be found in the
level of the default setting because
that's really what you're presenting at
a sort of public face of the program is
when and what were the parameters for
these initial modeling operations that
really I think end up generating from
bottom up the overall look of the
program or the month of the models that
come from and what were the initial sort
of parameters of I want to generate a
box I want to fill it that well where
you're quite what was your criteria for
determining these prophecies okay so
last a second question because when this
they don't remember the first one have a
very short term memory so as in terms of
like what how we identified the work
close to arrive to like the subset of
the tools we actually what we did is we
will in the interviews that we read with
the group that we call the teachers we
also got a lot of material like project
examples right so we would look at that
then we think okay this is the end
product right and we have talked with
them we have isolated the faces in terms
of like how they arrived to that product
so we actually I mean box was a very
simple example that I
mentioned but we would look at like
number of different end results you know
like reconstruct how they arrived there
and then go back and make those
workflows to identify what needs to be
the tool set that we identified is the
one that needs to happen there there
were like funny things that happen I
mean this is like geeky of me to say but
I mean for example the Phillip to let
you mentioned in previous rivet it was
embedded like three or four you know
hierarchies down people didn't even know
we have it and by being us to bring it
and like placing it like in the toolbar
that I showed suddenly we were getting
feedback but thank you that if you're
finally like have like a filler tool
when in fact it was there or like five
or six years and that is to explain that
I mean you know you need to be also very
careful about like which kind of tools
your feature because those are the kinds
of want that people actually want to see
first I'm sorry about your first
question maybe did you catch the first
question we can I
how do you mean the user interface
design process change the tool so not
which for example I'm in a very literal
example would be like the parameters for
the Phillip time because I'm interested
in how the specific way you interact
with the two ends up generating changing
the form that you know I'm sure now that
you have a fillip to available
everyone's using floods on a bit of a
sudden it's like this new thing and all
maybe all these buildings have Phillips
around there only if simply because
people are selling designing this simply
because it's available so sort of like
that always in a van example in which
like some specific aspect like the
parameters that you have put it the
Phillips will change because you realize
that people weren't using it properly or
like the way a curve is your honor like
acid of Micro Micro changes of the
interaction well I mean you see we
develop tools right can i have your
mobile phone right there we go I mean
maybe we developed like something like
this right and iPhone and beautiful I
mean I cannot control what kind of
conversations people have rib is like
one you can get like a really really bad
phone I mean
message from the type and although it's
like absolutely beautiful so I mean it
descends I mean you can't control
exactly how people are going to use
exactly what is available so in that
context I mean while we design tools and
we make them available it's up to those
that are like end users that decide how
they're going to use them so if somebody
goes off and uses like one tool I mean
that is an issue but that's more to talk
about you know what their own design
processes are then what the tool maker
has provided yeah I was just going to
mention that like in the direction
industry in the motion picture business
special effects with Maya we found that
there was a trend towards more and more
customization so at the end you would
visit a site like Disney or somebody and
you would sit down and you couldn't even
recognize that it was Maya because they
completely customized everything and
they full-time programmers working on
developing a custom interfaces and
custom tools just remove one even one
character or even one part of a
character so that's in the long term
that's probably the trend little that'll
go into the other design tools where
there will be a spectrum of how
different people use them and how even
within a single shop you'll have a sort
of a best practices of the local
programming group that will create the
tools of that that are the best
practices within office so we'll take
one or two more questions
musicians like fairly rudimentary just
like move around panels so I mean we my
hat on for would have was like really
screws I mean that's the extent because
so far would I what I've noticed is that
you're setting up certain tools in the
foreground where as what is honesty
there's a tendency for the user to be
able to create his own interface and
then you know have a multiplicity of
interfaces community right so we see
actually both cases I mean like the
question is like as the user wants to
the tool to like you know make most of
the driving or do they want to make like
a car of their own so we see a lot of
customization we are the API where
people actually develop their own tools
and those like start to like merge
I would like to talk to us reit nice
presentation which was super clear but
as the one person didn't use the word
parametric you had four examples I'm not
going to ask about the big shop which is
in a way kind of social parametric in a
certain way it's really interesting but
I want to talk about the other three two
of which the concave and convex use one
of the I was the ancient parametric and
amorphous and more versus as a form of
visual parametrics as their mode and
then do something with that in terms of
the computational shift and then the the
other one akin member was called now but
where you see good and bad information
in a way in a parametric not quite
gradient but possibility of re
developing the parametric relation
between them but you never use the word
parametric do you do is that a term that
you're involved with or and if not is
there a reason why it's not appropriate
or useful to you I mean the simple
answer is that before I got here I
didn't know that this session was called
post better net
no I would have used it one way or the
other mother but you know firstly just
talking about computational imaging
which is basically what what I do on
what I talked about the idea there is
twofold you have traditional imaging
traditional imaging is cameras for
photography for television for
scientific imaging remote sensing and
then you can go on into medical imaging
x-rays all of that is images images of
imaging is massive the whole idea behind
computational imaging is to use
simultaneously computations and optics
and in doing so we want to achieve two
things one is to come up with new
functionalities for images so think
about them as functionalities that the
field field of view depth etc the second
one which is actually more interesting
perhaps is to break the fundamental
limits of imaging using computations so
let me give you an example then I'll get
it into the answer to your question the
example is that if you wanted to capture
an image of this room which doesn't have
just tens of mega pairs but has a
billion pixels at gigapixel image or
maybe a terra pixel image then it turns
out that traditional optics doesn't
allow you to do it in any reasonable
form factor so I'd love to do it with
something that's roughly the size
the camera I can do it by using hundreds
of imaging systems create a massive
imaging system with these modules and
then i'm using scale to solve the
problem one of the questions is how do
you then use the same form factor of an
existing camera to break that
fundamental limit and it turns out that
if you use computations and design your
optics so as to go with the competition
and you can capture an image which has
embedded inside of it a gigapixel worth
of information and then recover it after
the fact so our parameters so to speak
are less geometric but more to do with
the realm of photometry radiometry which
is the study of light plus geometry you
throw this for things there are many
parameters there and be a very
parametric in that sense but not in the
perhaps in traditions as a long
incarnations of the series and that is
in computer science everything is
parametric you can't you can't not be
parametric so all these things are
defined from your software up to so the
higher level conceptual ideas by default
there parametric and it's not a it's so
ubiquitous it's like talking about you
know oxygen in the air you breathe it's
there's no mean two exits just
everywhere so it has no buzz associated
with it there's no value in mentioning
it because it's the one thing that
relies on for most the systems that come
out of the department and that the R&D
there as well so you know here it has a
certain meaning its associated a certain
way of doing things but over they are
much less so I would paraphrase the
trees parameter space as being
space-time trade
that's it
I guess I wanted to ask about the one
thing that mark actually mentioned and
left out the social aluminum and I guess
the way to fragment question best would
be in the car industry analogy this idea
of a forest in the days of Portsmouth
Taylorism and now if you argued this
post forest era which you know it's
maybe mark like flexible accumulation
and other staples how essentially the
strategies of what we call parametric or
automation of data translate to
relationships between people
specifically in your own research that
were different than before this
technology was here has it be structured
very tangibly the work environment and
more metaphysically the global
interaction
I mean I honestly don't work on the team
that does good collaboration but we have
a whole team that actually deals with
collaboration I mean the teams are
increasingly mobile that project five or
six implications in the world they are
utilizing the harnessing of information
from the same model and work I don't
know what plans are you know because i
have little been focusing on the
collaboration parts
but there's the spectrum that its
coordination and collaboration I think
sometimes we found or forget that
differentiation right so we also work
over multiple time zones 13 and the
collaboration part is as much of a
challenge as any coordination it's going
to happen over assets or work items into
that so I'm not answering your question
I'm making it a very nasty I mean to
that point actually when Jason and I
talked this summer about this research
that each of you to the fair running and
I shook her of the cards including
collaboration level of detail
coordination and so forth so like these
are the kinds of topics that we
investigate as well they're not
particular to the architecture same
happened like later visited games design
work with people that are actually
designed as working like for 300 people
consultancy stale answer it's not
something which is you know particular
to
I mean maybe two to wrap it up I I have
a couple of observations that I think
are a little bit relevant although maybe
not the same social aspect that you're
getting at least one but in in my
thinking about research I just want to
quickly know some things that you know
may be obvious to some people but may be
worth noting in in this room you know to
it to a room of architects and people
who think a lot about architecture which
is the the culture of research and I
just came from a science conference and
at this science conference almost all of
the presentations did something similar
to what Sri did which is show prior work
that's been published and cite the
authors and not only show that but that
makes for a really different slideshow
than we often see in this room but
really build off of it and the the
research itself that's published in the
papers is documented in a way that can
be understood and replicated and built
off of and I think you know just to put
models on the table partly because this
session is called research as a subtitle
I think that's that's really worth
stopping to recognize for us in this
room second I want to note that when I
was started thinking about models for
architecture R&D and I was having a hard
time finding good examples of firms or
in education at least in the same way
that that some kinds of R&D is thought
of in terms of big budgets long-term
research I was actually super pleasantly
surprised to meet azam about a year ago
and I
of course the the people who are doing
R&D in the field of architecture are the
software companies because I heard about
him and his work and so that was the
ingredient that I didn't describe in the
intro but it's clear from the projects
you know that you've heard about it
tonight from Autodesk but for many
others that that you could look up on
their websites including Autodesk
research that they're doing incredible
rd that's not even some of it not even
tied to a product release that's just
you know what I would think of as like
R&D it's like its long-term research
exploratory and it's not tied to a
single application and finally when
Michael and I were thinking about the
way to introduce this event we both
independently came across an article in
The New York Times just from no one
knows when it's published anymore
because you read it online but I read it
yeah saturday or yesterday and Annie was
about it IBM an apple did you read this
one your company but it basically was
talking about the in a way a culture of
research and it said that IBM actually
does a lot of researcher rd and it
basically cited that they have
laboratories around the world they spend
six billion dollars a year on research
and development they generate more
patents a year than they and then any
other company 5 IBM scientists of won
Nobel prizes the company's researchers
attend scientific conferences published
papers and have made fundamental
advances in computing material science
and mathematics so it's just a certain
culture of investing in research in a
way that we may not know where it's
going but it's it but it's somehow
important to the advance of our field
and I you know if anything I just want
to kind of close with that as an
observation but maybe also call to
action for our field to take what
lessons we can and maybe take another
lesson from Jacqueline which would be if
we don't have IBM
you know six billion dollars a year then
maybe we can still do research with this
under the radar approach but it would
probably have to borrow like more
deliberately on some other models for
research like the the science type of
research the documenting our findings so
that others can build off of them but
being clear about the result and and not
only kind of obscure an atmosphere well
my entire presentation wasn't cleared by
legal aspects of it are already patented
so we are out there above radar in
certain parts of what we're doing and a
choice that this group made early on is
about seven of us is that we're kind of
going the more academic route at the
outset and see if these logs gain any
traction in a more conference excuse me
or patenting environment and then
possibly use that as
yeah well and and so you know the last
words we are in a university we have
great models here and also models from
the corporate world like awesome running
this conference which I encourage you to
check out which the deadline is in four
days to submit to that but you know
maybe we should maybe we shouldn't
engage that more and we we have it all
around us in our software companies in
our departments across the way in our
colleagues I don't know if you have any
any lass all or else my own last words
are thank you very much for coming from
near and far it's it's always it's
always a delight to hear people from you
know do the same kind of you know the
thing would look the same in the
business card but approach you're so
disparate that it's yet progress kids
made so it's interesting stuff and thank
you very much for your retox tonight